Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Continuing
Chapter number five
the chapter regarding vigilance of Allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala
authored by
the first narration therein the
narration of
and which many of us are familiar with
in which
tells us that a man with very black hair
and very white clothing, not recognized
by anyone,
however did not appear to be a traveler,
entered the masjid and he came to the
front and came very close to the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam. At the end of
this narration,
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam is
going to say
to Omar
That was Jirel who came to teach you
your religion.
Everything here,
what we understand from this holistic
statement is that everything that
Gibbrel does or says in this narration
is part of our religion
unless
it clashes with any else. So what I mean
by that for instance, he addresses him
by his first name, Yah Muhammad, right?
This is inappropriate.
This either occurred before
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala prohibited
that
addressing him by his first name
either before he that prohibition was
revealed the end of which is later in
the Medani days
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
or this is all in order to
draw the attention of anyone who hasn't
already
paid attention. Why?
Because all of the companions know, all
of the near companions, the close
companions, they know that it is not
permissible
to address the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam by his first name.
out of respect.
This is part of
he is either referred to as
or he is referred to as Allah or
so
the prophet sallall.aii
is not addressed that way. You would not
hear that
term. You would not
it it was not something that they would
often hear. Yah Muhammad. So when they
hear that word, it's an alert.
Immediately everyone turns to see who is
this person who is speaking this.
And this is important for the purposes
of Gi's arrival
in order for everyone present to pay
very close attention.
So
here Jirelam
comes very close to the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam. This is the first
thing we learn from him.
The first thing we learn is coming close
to the teacher,
not being far. The prophet sallallah.aii
Wasam said to the companions once,
seeing them scattered out and far,
he said, "Your distance,
I only perceive it as being something
from a shaitan
that a shaitan has driven you to do."
The second thing we see from him is that
that he was close enough to where his
knees
were
to the knees of the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam. What does that mean?
That he's completely facing him.
This is not just respect for a teacher.
Not just respect for the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam or respect. This
is a general respect that the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam would even show
anyone else that spoke to him.
He was described that if he would turn
to speak to someone, he would turn to
them entirely.
Because when we as human beings, most of
what we say is with our tongue or with
our actions and our behavior with our
actions and behavior and postures and
body language. This is what most of what
we say is. So when I sit, imagine for
instance, imagine if
you and I were sitting together and you
were or even imagine that your son, your
daughter, someone that you're trying to
teach
is sitting
facing away from you or facing the wall
and you're sitting over here and they're
not looking at you, but they're
listening saying, "Yes, would this be an
appropriate posture of
edep, an appropriate posture of
of etiquette
in speaking to anyone. This is
considered to be very rude.
Let alone when we are in the process of
learning our religion,
you face the teacher. When a teacher is
speaking, you turn and you face him. You
would face away from him in the case
that you don't view this person as a
teacher. You view this person as you
know just somebody talking and he's not
talking to me. So you would look at the
wall and listen that way. And this is
something that our teachers pick up on.
And when we treat people a certain way,
they will treat us back a certain way.
He says,
"And he placed his hands on his thighs
this." He didn't lean over, sit
back, chillaxing, waiting to take it all
in. Ya Allah, talk to me. Tell me Islam.
Right?
He sat up faced the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam close put his hands on
his thighs.
Right? How do we learn?
The scholars tell us the five steps of
learning and retaining knowledge.
All of these five steps begin with what?
What are the five steps of learning and
retaining knowledge that the taught us?
The the taught us such as Zi Abdullahbn
Mubarak and others
taught us that proper learning
has five steps.
any one of these five steps is missing
the knowledge will not e either not be
learned or it will be deficient.
Number one,
[Silence]
how do we learn something? Five steps.
Number one,
proper question.
Number two,
proper listening and understanding.
Number three
is
proper memorization because knowledge is
two halves, understanding and
memorization. When those two meet, we
have knowledge.
Number four
is that a person implements what they
have learned. And number five that if
they have fulfilled all the previous
four steps they then teach it to others.
This is the etiquette and this is the
path of knowledge.
When you meet someone as we've mentioned
before who is of high level of knowledge
not just superficial knowledge we're
speaking about high level of knowledge.
the details that other people don't even
know exist.
That level of knowledge tells us two
things about this person's history.
Number one, this person has incredible
etiquette and knew how to bring that
knowledge out of his teachers. That's
number one. Number two, this person
knows how to ask a question.
, I know this is kind of but because
we're in America, anyone here ever see
Jeopardy
the game Jeopardy? You know, you know
how the answers all have to be in the
form of a question? It's because all
knowledge fundamentally is starts with a
question. All knowledge is a question,
right? All knowledge is an answer to a
question. All knowledge begins with a
question. a proper question. The
knowledge is deficient when a person
doesn't know how to ask a question
properly. And so the companions would
sometimes mle over a question
for months before actually presenting it
to the teacher.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala said,
[Silence]
This is speaking to two people.
to two people
Abbass
few men in the history of Islam 1,500
years of the brightest minds and the
purest of hearts.
Few men
who are more advanced than Ib Abbass in
understanding the Quran. You could count
them on your fingers.
That is how knowledgeable Ib Abbass is
with regard to the Quran.
He's also a family member of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam. So honoring him is
part of our religion.
Right? However,
Abdullahb Abbass, let's look at his
story. Abdullahb Abbass spent an entire
year
waiting
to ask Omar
who was meant by this verse.
[Silence]
So he's speaking to his wives, speaking
to two of them. At one time he had nine
wives simultaneously. Which two is he
speaking about?
An entire year he spent before he found
the proper words to adequately represent
the question he is asking and two before
he summed up the audacity
to ask
when did he ask him? He asked him while
they were traveling to go for Hajj. And
Omar
stopped in the caravan to go and relieve
himself. And Iban Abbass
carried his
carried his water for him to clean
himself after he relieved himself.
And then he said after all of that and
he found that he had an opportunity
Allah says
such and such who were intended by this
for I have spent a year working up the
courage and the words to ask you about
this verse.
Men,
who's intended by this verse? Anyone
know?
[Arabic recitation]
That's how it was. So,
right. Not just
Yeshu.
Yeah, I know. I know that. I already
know that. But tell me this here. Yeah.
Well, I already know that, but I I read
that and I read this and I know this and
I know that. So, tell me this little
part here because I really don't need
you for anything else except this little
part here.
That's a a bull in a china closet.
It's a bull in in a china store as
they say.
It's this is what we refer to as
someone asks a question this.
Who is one of the most knowledgeable
students of Ib Abbass? What kind of men
did he raise?
Ab
lived to be over 90 years old
was the sole muti of Mecca. as long as
he was alive after
it was decreed by the itself
punishable by law
that if someone is to give a fatwa in
Mecca while is in Mecca within its walls
this person answers to the Khalifa
himself.
What did I say? He said he remember he
lived to be over 90 years old. One of
the most senior students of Iban Abbas.
He said,
[Silence]
He said a man will
relate a narration or quote a narration
that I am so familiar with. I learned
and memorized this narration before this
person was born.
Yet when a person relates a narration to
me, I listen with the intensity
and the humility of someone who has
never heard this narration before,
right? for instance, when you try
to speak to someone, you say
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says,
We all know this verses, right?
I challenge you to get these verses out
of your mouth to anyone before they cut
you off and recite them for you because
God forbid someone think that you don't
know something, right? Allah says that
yeah, yeah, I know. I know. I know. I
know. The worst thing you could say with
the people of knowledge is I know.
And so
due to his respect and his for knowledge
and its position is that a child would
narrate a narration to him and he would
listen to it as if he's never heard it
before. This is how these men reach
these heights. Etiquette, right?
And so
somebody says his words to you, you
listen. You don't cut them off.
Right? And for this reason, the scholars
tell us in the etiquets of seeking
knowledge,
[Silence]
They say
that if you meet the people of
knowledge, make your constant mantra and
the thing you say the most I don't know
because if you tell the people of
knowledge I don't know not just with
your words with your actions with your
behavior which they will teach you until
you know
and the worst thing you can say in the
presence of the people of knowledge is I
know because if you tell the people of
knowledge I know they will continue to
ask you until you don't know
[Arabic recitation]